Speaker 1: A few of you from Canada wrote
to me about this and said, David, did you
hear that?
Joe Rogan has canceled his show in Vancouver,
Canada, over the vaccine requirement?
Yes, indeed, yes.
Indeed, for people who don't know what's going
on, Joe Rogan has called off a sold out comedy
show in Vancouver because of the vaccine requirement.
Vancouver City News writes popular podcast
podcast host and UFC commentator Joe Rogan
has confirmed he's canceled his 420 show,
meaning April 20th in Vancouver due to vaccine
mandates.
Speaking on a Christmas Eve episode of his
podcast.
He said quote, I should probably say this
because I haven't yet.
My 420 show that sold out in Vancouver, I
don't think that's happening.
I don't think I can even get into the country.
I'm not vaccinated.
I'm not going to get vaccinated.
And subsequently also posting to his Facebook
page that that indeed is what's happening.
The show is getting canceled.
Currently, people coming into Canada from
the U.S. must show proof of vaccination, and
a negative test proof of vaccination is also
required to attend events like the one Rogen
had planned.
So not only would Rogen need to be vaccinated
to go to Canada.
All of the attendees would need to show proof
of vaccination in order to go to the event
itself, Rogen said.
He quote doesn't trust that Vancouver won't
cut capacity at arenas.
However, the province made the move to restrict
capacity by 50 percent at venues with more
than a thousand seats that was announced a
week before Rogen made the comments.
Rogers Arena saying per the announcement of
the province of British Columbia, capacities
will be reduced to 50 percent with rising
COVID cases.
We keep working with local health authorities
to support each other.
Rogen has opposed vaccine mandates and to
some degree vaccinations and announced to
his millions of followers in September that
he had indeed tested positive.
I have to tell you, I have been so critical
of so many of the things that Joe Rogan said
for so long about the vaccine.
I think he's been.
Dead wrong about so many of the things that
he said, many of you have written to me and
that you've said, David, we appreciate that
you are willing to criticize Joe Rogan for
the things he says about the vaccine, because
so many of your other cohorts are not willing
or are not interested in doing that.
I think it's important to call things out
when you see them, when they don't make sense.
But on this particular decision, I'm glad
to see Rogan make this decision.
What do I mean by that?
It would actually be glaring hypocrisy, presumably
based on lining his pockets.
If he said these things on the podcast for
a year or more and then went and said, Oh
yeah, and you got to be vaccinated to come
to my show and now I'm going to get vaccinated,
only to be able to do the show and make money.
Like, in other words, there's so much criticism
that I've made about Joe Rogan.
It is logical to me, and it suggests that
at least it's not a grift what he's saying.
He's misinformed.
He's been empirically wrong about many of
the things that he said.
He's brought on various guests who also say
things that are completely wrong, but he genuinely
seems to believe it and is not abandoning
it in order to just do the show and make the
money to some degree.
I'm glad to see that rather than him reversing
simply in order to be able to do the show
and make the money.
Now it's reported that the show is canceled,
but is also rescheduled for like almost a
year from now.
So whether we call it a postponement or a
cancelation, it's not clear that you're no
longer going to need to be vaccinated in a
year to get into Canada.
So that remains to be seen.
But to some degree, at least, he is sticking
by what he claims to say.
And if nothing else, it means he really believes
that he's wrong.
He's wrong, but at least he seems to really
believe it and not be doing it for the clicks,
which I did not suspect.
I suspected all along that as wrong as I believe
Joe Rogan is on this stuff, these really are
his beliefs